sie versüßt dir die weihnachtszeit
du siehst du dich mit banken vom alltag
gefreut
die beiden freuen
das ist
dies wird
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute geht's ganz leckere
kartoffeln aus dem backofen und ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz
die zutaten
ich hab hier zwölf kleine kartoffeln das
sind vorwiegend festkochende dann
brauche ich etwas olivenöl vereins bis
zwei teelöffel salz und pfeffer und
später brauche ich dann noch etwas lax
da habe ich jetzt geräucherten lachs
genommen 200 gramm und etwas schmand
oder saures sahne und das gericht das
könnte jetzt auch ganz gut vorbereiten
und den lachs und entschwand brauche ich
dann auch erst später also zuerst müsst
ihr natürlich die kartoffeln erst mal
waschen die habe ich schon gewaschen und
jetzt hat er sie und ich habe mir auch
schon ein backblech mit backpapier
gerichtet und den backofen auf 220 grad
ober unterhitze vorgeheizt
und jetzt höre ich die kartoffeln innen
etwas aus einfach so eine kleine
halbkugel und die mister nicht
wegschmeißen
die könnte zum beispiel weiter benutzen
wenn ihr das supermacht und könnt ihr
dann einfach so als suppeneinlage mit
rein nehmen
und jetzt gebe ich da noch etwas
olivenöl drauf und bestreitet alle
kartoffeln also geradezu eins bis zwei
teelöffel und das ganz schön auf die
oberfläche
und jetzt werden sie noch mit salz und
pfeffer gewürzt und kommen dann in den
backofen bei 220 grad für ungefähr 30
minuten bis sie schön weich sind und
danach geht's dann auch gleich weiter
die kartoffeln sind jetzt abgekühlt und
ich habe übrigens die kleinen
ausgehöhlten teile auch noch etwa zehn
minuten mit in den backofen gegeben da
kann man die einfach so verwaschen und
jetzt bereite ich noch den schmand vor
und zwar musste jetzt auch nur ein
bisschen gewürzt werden mit salz und
pfeffer
natürlich können da auch andere kräuter
noch mit rein geben wenn ihr möchtet
diese würde auch ganz gut passen weil
wir gleich noch laxen eingeben
red
neben salz müsste jetzt ein bisschen
aufpassen weil wir gleich noch
geräuchert und lachs mit drauf und da
ist auch schon ziemlich witzig und
salzig und jetzt kann ich eigentlich
auch schon direkt anrichten
ich habe hier eine schieferplatte und
setzt die kartoffeln jetzt da drauf aber
normaler teil da geht natürlich auch
da kommt jetzt immer so ein teelöffel
verschwand mit drauf
jetzt zerreisst sich den langsam ein
bisschen mit zwei gabeln und setzt ihn
dann obendrauf einfach so viel wie er
möchte
und falls er kein lachs mit könnte zum
beispiel auch hähnchenbrustfilet nehmen
oder irgendwie was anderes was euch gut
dazu schmeckt aber ich denke hähnchen
fuß passt auch ganz gut dazu vor allem
wenn die auch geräuchert ist dies dann
auch schön würzig und ansonsten können
es auch einfach werden lassen
jetzt habe ich hier noch bisschen
schnittlauch dann habe ich mir gerade da
hinten abgeschnitten und den schneide
ich jetzt hier noch drüber und das passt
halt farblich aber auch geschmacklich
richtig gut dazu
b
ich habe die charta fleckchen eben schon
probiert sie sind wirklich sehr lecker
man kann sie eigentlich so aus der hand
essen also eigentlich ist es ein
fingerfood nur verträgt sich das im
moment in meinem lippenstiften der
deswegen geht es wird also habe ich mit
gabel und messer gegessen
auf jeden fall sind sie wirklich sehr
lecker ihr könnt zum beispiel auch so
ein kaltes buffet anrichten oder auch
einfach mal so zum mittagessen oder zum
abendessen als kleinen snack wobei ein
kleiner snack ich nicht weil kartoffeln
sind eher ziemlich sättigend und in
verbindung mit dem lachs weg nicht total
lecker und wenn ihr das gerne nachmachen
volt gibt es das rezept auf meinem blog
auf salehs - blog.de und ich freue mich
wenn ihr das nach macht und mir auch ein
bild auf facebook oder instagram schickt
bis zum nächsten mal